always
already god
an unconditionally free singularity
right now is the mystery
talking to itself
across what appears
to be a dissociative boundary
where
life somehow accumulated
all of these identities and all of these
attributes the sense of i
the sense of me the sense of
my the sense of mine
and then this big list of identifiers
name career etc
there's a big list of likes and dislikes
attachments cravings aversions
indifferences apathies
and then this life begins
associating itself perpetually with all
of those
identifiers and attributes
and life forgets that it is life
without those identifiers and attributes
[Laughter]
there is an apparent forgetting and an
apparent
remembering which is this
one infinite mystery
undergoing the apparent forgetting
of itself on into this
illusion mirage bubble
of identity and attachment
and attributes and aversions
i me my mind
and then there's an apparent liberation
of said contracted
identification into what is
the one infinite mystery itself which is
what was there the entire time
the person or the contraction was
just a dream it was just an illusion it
was just a mirage
ooh funny ass games funny ass
games that we
as this infinite mystery play with
ourselves
what could be more fun
than to create a universe and create
planets and stars and civilizations and
conscious agents
talking to each other many of which the
majority of which
have absolutely forgotten themselves as
this one infinite intelligence
have absolutely forgotten themselves as
god as a singularity
as oneness and then undergoing the
process of
waking up from that contraction
into the always already freedom
unconditional that it had always been
so many planets orbiting stars so
many civilizations secreted
so much biology that has evolved
conscious agents that are self-aware
that are able to reflect on their
existence
that then forget that they are god
that they are an infinite singularity
and then get
intoxicated by the illusion of
separation
it's a very intoxicating illusion this
separation thing
it's so intoxicating
and so is the intoxicating
attachment to sensation
into experience
into
not liberating oneself
from sensation and from experience
and from the vicissitudes these ups and
downs
of pain and pleasure
liberate yourself from the ups and downs
of pain and pleasure
liberate yourself into the uncontracted
unbounded freedom that you already are
without any identity
without any attachment without any
aversion
to this ineffable
always already free in wholeness
because when you are absolutely
whole already and always
you don't ever try to extract
worthiness or validation or peace or
happiness
from outside
and so you are enlightened because you
are the sun
you've recognized yourself as the sun
and so now all you do is you illuminate
all you do is illuminate this is what's
meant by pure service
honor duty joy
peace freedom happiness
a state of meditative economist
consciousness that is
constantly in union with infinity
it's also in union with emptiness
and it's comfortable with being in union
with emptiness
and by being in union with emptiness
it's able to
see the arising and passing of
sensations and of experiences and it
never
gets triggered neuroscientifically it
never gets
this trigger cascade and then before you
know it
already reacting with
craving attachment or aversion
dislike
and then you get better and better at
this process
it may have taken you five minutes of
suffering
before recognizing that you were lost in
some sort of a train
of discursive thinking
and all of a sudden you go
whoa i was just in a train of five
minutes of discursive thinking
and you're like thank goodness that i
remembered how to breathe
oxygen
relax tension dissolve
and it goes from taking five minutes to
do that
to only taking three minutes to do that
to only taking one minute to do that
to only taking 15 seconds to do that
and then before you know it this
incredible
miracle happens and you become really
aware where
you watch the arising of this
discursive thought of i don't
and then it dissolves
and you're back in this empty cognizance
you're back in this always already free
god unconditional singularity
and you're just mind blown
because you're now able to so
beautifully watch that the sensation
the experience has no trigger
no cascade and you can just
perpetually abide
in infinity in emptiness
in the singularity that you've always
been the whole time but you assumed
i me my mine attributes
personality identifiers
name career friends
family likes dislikes
all of this for what
for the game
for the game for lila for the divine
play that this is
and then
you get it you just get it
and there's nothing left to
get but there's just more to deepen
and there's just more love
there's more freedom there's more
wisdom there's more child like innocence
play laughter infinity
there's more of that for you to relax
into for you to fall into
silence for you to fall into stillness
for you to fall into spontaneity in this
natural state of joy and peace
and freedom and expression in pure
service
to the creation to you
the mystery awakening to itself
and so you see there's a big difference
between being a contracted
person that feels separate
that is not whole and that needs to
fulfill
that not wholeness with
outside validation outside
experiences or substances or
relationships or material possessions
versus when that person finally
experiences enough
suffering to where they turn
inward and they begin investigating
self-inquiry who am i
who is i what is
i and in doing so
by just simply asking themselves with a
great amount of earnestness
and fanning this flame under their ass
to understand that this entire time
they've been
generating the illusion generating the
mirage
of all of these identities and
attributes and likes
and dislikes cravings aversions
and they've been driving themselves
into all of this insanity and suffering
never even able to just pause and just
i exist how cool is this wow
look at life look at the universe
so cool
and they finally get it they're like i
assumed
this illusion i assumed this mirage
all these identifiers and attributes
cravings and aversions
but what i was the entire time
was this ineffable infinite mystery
where there's no separation none
zero zilch nada
none no separation none
all is one period
you've assumed yourself to be
a contracted separate person
with all of those identifiers and
attributes and as soon as you just turn
inward and begin the process of
self-inquiry
you will feel more and more liberated
every single day
you will feel more and more like you are
already always god
an unconditionally free singularity
wholeness perpetually
pure service child-like
innocence sage-like
wisdom equanimity
and peace that's imperturbable no
sensation or experience can trigger any
cascade
beautiful mystical union with emptiness
and simultaneously beautiful mystical
union
with infinity
no longer seeing a person
as an other person
but instead seeing them as the one
seeing them as you they are you
and you are them as soon as you
burst out of your skin into
transpersonality transpersonalism
into non-duality as soon as you
burst outside of your skin outside of
your identity outside of your attributes
outside of your cravings and aversions
you deepen your union with the very
substrate itself
what could be more beautiful
than this than this game that we
architect and play with ourselves
the one generating this game
of forgetting and remembering
of hide and seek
and how funny is it
when we break ourselves out of the
mirage
when we shatter ourselves out of the
cageless
cage and we recognize that we were
it the whole time
the whole time
no separation none zero
zilch nada this is all you
this is all you this is all you
all is you all of it all of it
all that's you
appearing like a universe appearing
like differentiation
you have to go all the way to the root
you have to go
all the way to source
you have to go all the way
to the nature of your existence
the essence of your existence
and the moth
dissolves into the flame and there's
just
that infinite singularity that's left
and then all that's left is pure service
all that's left is childlike innocence
honor duty joy
wisdom peace
and for many of you that is why you came
here
you came here to quickly
parse for signal and break out of your
mirage
so that you could recognize yourself as
the one infinite creator
and then serve the creation
you came specifically for that
so remember that
as soon as you can prioritize that
as much as you can
the more earnestness that you have
to get to the root to get to the essence
of yourself as always
already god an unconditionally free
singularity
the faster that truth will yield
stop delaying your turn to
self-inquiry nothing
externally will satiate you
nothing
nothing
and it's even worse
that when you talk to people that you
see yourself as a separate person
talking to a separate person
you're so caught in your own
contractions
your own trigger cascades
your own conditioning frameworks
turn inward onto those conditioning
frameworks onto those
trigger cascades understand how
sensation affects your neurology
practice equanimity practice
metacognition
gain awareness over your thought process
liberate yourself from the contraction
rather than seeing two separate
people talking to each other you will
always and forever see only
the one you will be only
the one
you will be talking to yourself
in that interaction
you will be serving the other person
purely
because they are you and you know that
you're helping them you're serving them
honorably with wisdom
peace joy innocence play
not trying to extract worthiness or
validation from them
becoming aware of your conditioning
aware of your likes and your dislikes
becoming aware of the sense of i me
mine
and all of the identities
and attributes
that we have yet to actually become
aware of
we're mechanic we're robotic
we're scripted it's just
scripts likewise
was very scripted now
much more liberated
free yourself
you're already the
one infinite mystery you're already it
but it is like the back
of your hand
and all you have to do is look
at the back of your hand that's the one
infinite mystery
but you've only been looking at your
sense of
eye and all of your identity and
attributes and likes and dislikes and
indifferences
that's all right here just look at the
source look at the root
itself look
at the one infinite mystery that is
behind everything
that is all of this at play with itself
wow
and then it's just the mystery that
moves you
god moves you dao moves you
brahman moves you
the mystery moves you infinity moves you
emptiness
moves you
because you are that the duality's been
collapsed
and all that's left is pure service to
life
to creation awakening
to doing great things like not only
awakening
consciousness on the turn inward but
into decentralizing
and universalizing the planetary
architectures
so that the material basic needs
oxygen
water food shelter safety survival
electricity education health care
renewable energy all of it can be met
it's much easier to manifest
said external architectures
by awakening to the unity of all
existence
and it's also simultaneously easier to
awaken to the unity of all existence
by having your basic needs be met the
two play on one
another science and spirituality
or materialism and consciousness they
play
into one another the two are one
ah
cool
that's all fam
miss three talking to the mystery love
talking to love truth talking to truth
reality talking to reality
life talking to life infinity talking to
infinity
period that's all
love you thank you
let me know how you feel in the comments
below we'd love to hear from you
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet and share the video with people that
you feel like this would profoundly
influence
got some epic massive things ahead
pumped
all right
peace love prosperity
awakening
always already god
unconditionally free
singularity
always already got
[Music]
unconditionally free
singing
hilarity
you